so the week has turned really bad for
Donald Trump on top of being booed at
the World Series game on top of getting
bad GDP numbers by his own standards
which I'll talk about later
despite the formalization of an
impeachment inquiry against him starting
to move forward in the house despite
being caught staging a Situation Room
picture 90 minutes after the raid that
led to the death of Isis leader Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi had ended there was
devastating testimony given against
Donald Trump by witnesses including
testimony that mentions that there was a
concerted effort to remove references to
Joe Biden and the company buries m'a in
that quote transcript of trump's july 25
phone call with the Ukrainian president
zalenski we are covering that piece
separately so I'm not going to get into
detail about it now but needless to say
it has thrown Donald Trump into one of
his tizzies this time forcing him to
burp out a series of panicked anti
impeachment rants riddled with
misspellings and all this guy knows he's
in trouble see if you can make heads or
tails out of this Trump tweeting
Republicans are very unified and
energized in our fight on the
impeachment hoax with the do-nothing
Democrats and now are starting to go
after the substance even more than the
very beat then the very in fair process
not unfair the in fair process because
just the casual reading of the
transcript leads everybody to see that
the call with the Ukrainian president
was a totally appropriate one as he said
no pressure
this impeachment nonsense is just the
continuation of the witch-hunt hoax
which has been going on since before I
even got elected Republicans go with
substance and close it out so understand
he's panicking because everything is
happening as it should and it's really
bad for him Nancy Pelosi and Democrats
are formalizing the impeachment inquiry
they're giving him the due process that
he claims to have been denied witnesses
are coming forward and saying what they
say
like for example lieutenant colonel
Alexander VIN Minh which we'll get to so
when you look at the substance of what
Trump is tweeting it makes no sense the
process is not unfair or in fair as
Trump says it's the same process that
took place with Bill Clinton
the transcripts lead everyone to see the
Ukraine call as appropriate he claims
well he who didn't release a transcript
you released some truncated nonsense and
even in and of itself it was
incriminating now it is being alleged
that specific mentions of Joe Biden were
removed from what you released his
continued references to that summary as
a transcript this has become one of the
most frequently repeated misleading
memes about this entire Fiasco that he's
made that it's a witch-hunt I mean he
says that about everything of course
that's not true so let's go back to the
basics is this how an innocent person
truly behaves but as I've been saying
for months if you think that this is
Trump starting to lose it just wait if
and until the public hearings begin it
will be a completely new Donald Trump
altogether the rants the tweets the
erratic behavior the attempts to cover
up it's going to get really really bad
and a little bit later I'll come back to
the testimony from Alexandrov Inman do a
cappucci paid for de Gracia Mila one of
our sponsors making the David Pakman
show possible is Babel the language
learning app and you'll get 25% off a
subscription to Babel when you click the
link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps they're learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used Babel
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on Babel only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and used Babel to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short amount of time
after practicing Italian on the babble
app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in
I could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend Babel to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to Babel when you
click the link right underneath this
video